what's up guys today we're gonna be
taking a look at coursers SP 120 RGB
fans let's jump right in so guys I got
three different SP 120s I didn't get the
3-pack because I didn't need a
controller because I have the coarser at
570 x case so that can support three
more fans but if you guys are looking at
buying these without the case then
you're gonna want to get the 3-pack
because that's what has a controller and
if you want to use RGB functionality of
this fan you're gonna want the
controller okay let's see what's inside
the supporters just a little sticker
right here it comes
a little bit force pulled it out inside
and there's two cables and also a little
warranty card the the reason that this
has to fan to cords is because one cord
goes to the controller the other trend
or the other are I mean that other cord
goes to other world
so you need a controller unless you
already have a case hey guys that's
that's the unboxing of the course here
at p120
let's see how it works with the 3-pack
fans of SP 120 you get a SP lighting
controller but you can stick onto your
case so allow you to change the speed
the color and browse those different
modes are available this is what I'll
overall allow you to change the
different effects of the RGB on the
Phoenix these fans come with the 2 year
warranty and their static pressure fans
obviously it produced 26s opposed of
sound and create static pressure to the
1.5 mm
the airflow is 52 CFM and unfortunately
they are not PWM controllable
finally there's fetus 1,400 revolutions
per minute plus or minus 10% okay guys
let me go through all the motors so this
first one right here it's a simple color
with pulsing passage this one changes to
difference all the different colors that
it has and it pulses the next mode is
just static
and this one is slow pulsing in the CFO
and here's a super fun super fast olsen
over here
you have to change the speed okay I hope
you guys enjoyed my coverage of the SP
120 RGB enhancement force here if you
guys liked the video make sure to give
it a like if you guys loved it and would
like to see more of these types of
videos and make sure to subscribe also
make sure to check out my other videos
and until next time bye